what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we break down the most powerful
characters and comics and today
we're looking at a villain that has
threatened the existence of the marvel
universe on more than one occasion even
going so far is to capture galactus and
this character
is pretty much guaranteed to make his
way to the mcu at some point in the
future
probably during the annihilation film of
course we are talking about
annihilus now annihilus was created by
stan lee and jack kirby and first
appeared in fantastic four annual number
six which was coincidentally the first
appearance of franklin richards so it
turned out to be a pretty significant
issue for the marvel universe and it was
actually sue storm's pregnancy with
franklin that brought the fantastic four
into contact with the nihilus for the
first time as they journeyed into the
negative zone where annihilus resided in
order to get some particles of
antimatter to treat some complications
to a pregnancy caused by her exposure to
cosmic radiation you know i always kind
of wonder
what made jack kirby design the negative
zone to look that way
i know what it was it was skillshare
brand deal time yes skillshare ladies
and gentlemen
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
where you can explore
new skills develop existing interests
and get lost in creativity now
we recently crossed two million
subscribers here on my youtube channel
and one of the questions that i get
all the time is how do you get to a
channel that big right how do you grow
on youtube here's the funny thing
there's an amazing class taught by a guy
named andy j
pizza which is an interesting name and
it's called find your style
five exercises to unlock your creative
identity and would you believe me if i
told you
classes like that are key to succeeding
on youtube because you don't just want
to be me
right you don't want to copy me you want
to have your own style if you fire up a
youtube channel and you're basically a
mini version of me you're never going to
get as big as me classes like this
will teach you how to develop your own
identity they'll teach you how to
develop your own youtube channel in such
a way to where it can become an
extension of yourself
everything ranging from developing huge
ideas to populating your world with
different concepts and philosophies
creating your own kind of style key
this will teach you that and that's the
benefit of skillshare it offers
membership with meaning where you can
connect with the support of fellow
creatives and enter a community of
encouragement communication and
inspiration
so the first 1 000 of my subscribers to
click the link in the description
will get a one month free trial of
skillshare so you can start exploring
your creativity today having said that
let's get back into our video
so the funny thing about an ils is he
came about after a ship carrying life
spores through the negative zone to see
life on various planets was hit by a
meteor sending its spores to a planet
known as
atheros now over the years one of those
spores would mutate and evolve into
annihilus who later found the crashed
ship
and absorbed all the information stored
in it making him incredibly intelligent
now
after gaining all this knowledge instead
of using it to try and better the world
around him
annihilus did exactly what i would
probably do because i love the idea of
being a villain he became obsessed with
killing anything
and everything that he perceives as
being any kind of a threat i'm a
terrible person but i'm sorry guys
if i gained superpowers i would become a
bad guy right like that's basically
exactly what i would do but annihilus
becomes the ruler of the negative zone
as well as becoming a frequent
antagonist of the fantastic four now as
far as his powers go annihilus has
enhanced physical attributes stemming
from his armored exoskeleton annihilus
has demonstrated incredible strength on
several occasions
often going toe-to-toe with some of
marvel's heaviest hitters and inflicting
some major damage in the process
he was able to straight thrash the
original captain marvel
punched through the force fields created
by quasar's gauntlets and
matched strength with thunderstrike who
was kind of like a knockoff version of
thor in the 1990s that nobody liked but
who was still pretty much equivalent to
thor in terms of power level now
annihilus was not only able to knock out
the thing but was also able to break off
a piece of his rocky hide which is
incredibly durable and has withstood
many punches from the hulk without
breaking so annihilus is definitely up
there among the strongest marvel
characters now his exoskeleton which is
made of an alloy of matter and
antimatter also affords nihilus a great
deal of durability as he's withstood
some of the heaviest hitters in marvel
comics for instance when the thing
punched the nihilus it actually injures
his hand and annihilus absolutely tanks
the human torch's nova flame which is
the hottest flame he can create it's the
temperature of the sun
annihilus was also able to withstand
strikes from thor
while he was wielding mjolnir a punch
from the incredible hulk which was
actually rick jones at the time not
bruce banner but he was still really
strong
and is unfazed by an attack from
blastart a character
that's destroyed planets so in addition
to possessing immense strength annihilus
is also
incredibly durable pretty much to the
point of being invulnerable
and annihilus durability is not limited
to purely physical attacks either
but he also seems to be immune to the
scarlet witch's hexes as well
so harming annihilus is not an easy task
by any means
now in addition to his strength and
durability a nihilist exoskeleton
allows him to survive the vacuum of
space but his exoskeleton
is only the beginning of his power set
as he is made
vastly more powerful by his mastery over
the cosmic control rod one of the most
powerful artifacts in the history of
marvel comics the cosmic control rock
those of you guys who don't know was
created by annihilus after he found the
starship that crashed in the negative
zone and put on a helmet that
transferred all the knowledge it
contained
into annihilus mind and since creating
it annihilus has used the cosmic control
rod for a variety of purposes
but mostly to prolong the lifespan of
his cells which has allowed him to live
far longer than he otherwise would since
insects typically have short lives but
the cosmic control rod allows the
nihilus to manipulate matter and energy
on the atomic level which he takes
advantage of to augment his physical
attributes to even greater proportions
and produce powerful blasts of cosmic
energy one of which was able to match
the energy blast from thanos
not only can annihilus use the cosmic
control rod to project energy but he can
also drain
energy from others as well and he's used
this to drain energy from characters as
powerful as odin and quasar and in the
latter instance once he drained quasar's
energy he also stole his quantum bands
making him
even more powerful the cosmic control
rod also grants the nihilists other
powers such as telekinesis and telepathy
and although annihilus is an extremely
powerful character in his own right
he's made even more formidable by his
control over the annihilation wave which
is
basically a massive army of insect-like
bugs and an armada of spacecraft that
have threatened the very existence of
the marvel universe in response to the
positive matter universe encroaching on
the negative zone annihilus
brings his annihilation wave into the
universe to conquer it and when i say
that the annihilation wave was the
threat to the universe's existence i'm
not exaggerating at all
one of the ships in annihilation's
armada is called the harvester of soros
which was able to destroy
entire planets and use their energy to
supply the rest of the wave with food
and fuel so planetary destruction is
definitely within annihilus abilities
through his annihilation wave
the wave was also able to take out the
entirety of the nova corps
break through the barriers separating
the positive and negative zones and most
impressively
kill galactus and all the celestials
unfortunately we are not explicitly told
or
shown how this happens but during jim
starlin's graphic novel
thanos the infinity finale were shown
the aftermath of it and the fact that
the annihilation wave was able to take
out galactus and the celestials is
incredibly impressive as those are some
of the most powerful entities in the
marvel universe and are
all far beyond omega level themselves
it's worth pointing out though that
during the annihilation event that
basically set the tone for the modern
cosmic landscape and comics galactus was
able to destroy the annihilation wave so
there is a fair bit of inconsistency
with regard to the relative power levels
of the annihilation wave and galactus
but that's to be expected when different
writers have different takes on
characters and concepts the other part
of that is
a lot of people look at jim starlin's
infinity series basically everything
after infinity war as being out of
continuity so
take that as you will but also during
annihilation annihilus attack
is repelled through a joint effort of a
ton of marvel cosmic heroes and
annihilus himself
is actually killed by nova but he would
not stay dead long
and was actually reborn as an infant
with all of his memories and this
actually sets up another one of
annihilus powers which is that each time
he dies he's reborn
making him effectively immortal as we
learn in fantastic four number
600 so it seems as if the marvel
universe will never be free of the
threat of annihilus and his annihilation
wave due to his seemingly compulsive
ability
for endless resurrection as well as his
ability to raise an army in a very short
period of time
which he's been able to do each time
they've been destroyed and yeah that's
pretty much all you need to know about
annihilus like i said
i can't imagine him not showing up in
the mcu sometime in the future because
he's just such a massive threat way more
of a threat than thanos ever was but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section do you guys think
you'll see annihilus in the mcu
let me know below thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace you